this week 48 Hours on a Cold Case murder
that stumped investigators for nearly 35
years Roxanne wood was found dead in her
Michigan home back in 1987. DNA from the
crime scene was preserved but there
wasn't enough evidence to charge any
suspects decades later a genetic
genealogist helped investigators find
the Killer by constructing a family tree
48 Hours correspondent Peter Van Sant
reports
in February 1987 Terry Wood came home
from a night of bowling to discover his
wife Roxanne dead on the kitchen floor
she was bleeding profusely from her neck
detective first lieutenant Chuck
Christensen says Roxanne had been
sexually assaulted and her throat was
slashed
DNA was preserved but given technology
limits at the time not much could be
done with it 34 long years passed
without a real lead I was starting to
lose hope then in 2021 investigative
genetic genealogist Gabriella Vargas got
to work on the Cold Case though only a
scant amount of DNA was left Vargas was
confident I believed that this case was
extremely solvable I believe that I
could solve it incredibly Vargas
identified a suspect in just four days
his name Patrick Gillum but before an
arrest could be made investigators had
to be sure gillum's DNA matched the DNA
left at the scene I'm Ryan cotty and I
am a trooper with the Michigan State
Police Coty went undercover following
Gillum we noticed that he was a smoker
it's a great source of DNA cut and his
team witnessed Gillum flick a cigarette
butt out his window as he drove you're
rubbing your hands you're going this is
going to be that final piece of the
puzzle that you had talked about right
yes they were in for some bad news it
wasn't a match it's possible the butt
picked up on a busy street wasn't the
one that Gillum tossed so Katie followed
him again I saw him throw his cigarette
which was right right in about this area
so it was a great situation because the
cigarette was by itself investigators
held their breath until the results from
this butt came back it was a perfect
match DNA had identified a killer but
could investigators get him to confess
Why didn't it match the first time so I
think because he was following a vehicle
and the it was a busy road it might have
been the wrong cigarette right that's
why he said it was a loan yeah he was
very happy about that catching a little
bag as well so